en avril 2010 s'ouvre est à elancourt le
pôle pilote de sécurité locale le pps lc
origine remonte même à 2800 but tester
les innovations technologiques et
surtout bénéficié d'un retour des
utilisateurs services de secours ou
encore forces de l'ordre presque trois
ans après quel est le bilan bonsoir à
jacqueline argens ça veut dire que la
directrice donc de ce ppsl depuis
l'origine depuis la création quel bilan
vous faites par rapport aux ambitions
qui étaient les vôtres en avril 2010
alors une grande satisfaction puisque on
a eu on a des très bonne interaction
avec les utilisateurs et on s'est aperçu
que quand on laissait du temps
de discussion ça permettait d'avoir des
idées très intéressantes très importante
pour améliorer les technologies qu'on
utilise actuellement donc c'était
vraiment très profitable j'ai donné en
sont sans doute quelques exemples très
certainement des questions forcément
quelques exemples de réalisations
peut-être concrètes qui ont vu le jour
grâce au pps m alors
qu'ils soient directement mis en
opération
actuellement c'est encore un peu court
c'est ce n'est pas encore le cas
puisqu'il a fallu le temps de faire du
recueil de besoins d'abord de ensuite
spécifier les priorités et après les
mettre en place des développements des
tests donc il n'ya rien encore qui est
directement opérationnels par contre il
ya des choses qui sont maintenant en
cours de test d'évaluation chez les
utilisateurs chez opérationnelle qui
j'espère seront opérationnels fin
d'année ou année prochaine forces de
l'ordre comme services de secours
pompiers voilà ce que tu as fait et même
peut-être services techniques des villes
oui effectivement c'est des outils qui
sont très utiles pour tous ceux et
celles qui est jumelé sur son
implantation en tout cas avec le
commissariat de la ville d'elancourt oui
on est effectivement les bâtiments sont
communs pas d'entrée direct évidemment
mais c'est une extension aussi des
commissariats de police qui ce bâtiment
d'ailleurs a été mis à disposition par
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la casse qui
pour le ps elle et ça nous est vraiment
très pratique on verra sans doute
quelques images on envoie en
actuellement effectivement
à elancourt justement vous avez évoqué
la création ses locaux qui ont été mis à
disposition par la communauté
d'agglomération qui participent au
financement également la ville en cours
et partenaires également et c'est un
partenariat surtout et c'est important
de le dire parce que c'est assez unique
qui s'était très novateur aussi à
l'époque partenariat public et privé
parce que c'était la volonté aussi d'une
entreprise qui s'est implantée sur le
territoire de saint quentin est en cours
ou eads d'avoir justement un outil comme
celui ci oui parce que on a besoin de
dialogue c'est à dire que si on reste
dans nos entreprises à penser au futur
tout seul eh bien on développe des
solutions qui ne sont pas adaptés et là
vraiment d'avoir une prise de conscience
des pouvoirs publics et des autorités
locales
dans ses besoins de créer des
technologies qui leur servent mais qui
servent aussi à développer des
entreprises du tissu local de saint
quentin et permettent de créer comme ça
des emplois c'est aussi leurs bénéfices
donc effectivement ils nous ont soutenus
dès le démarrage du projet et nous
soutiennent activement nous permettant
d'accéder à des des utilisateurs les
polices municipales par exemple qui sont
dépendantes des villes ça nous permet
aussi de regarder leurs besoins
justement on en revient au travail qui
est mené quelles innovations sont
véritablement réaliser quelques ailes
pistons on peut donner sans peut-être
dévoilé parce qu'il ya peut-être un
secret autour de certaines de ses
innovations comble mais ce soir mais on
est très très ouvert sur sur justement
la communication on a un site web
d'ailleurs dans lequel on retrouve
toutes ces informations
et des exemples m'a peut-être celui que
l'on vous on a vu sur les images qui est
le fait d'utiliser des grandes tables
interactives comme des iphone mais en
grandeur est très futuriste
mais tout à fait et donc ce type de
table ça permet d'avoir des utilisateurs
qui manipule les données ensemble et qui
permettent de réfléchir en temps réel à
une situation donc en cas de crise par
exemple quand il ya énormément
d'informations qui arrivent en même
temps c'est très difficile de comprendre
ce qui se passe ce type de table permet
d'avoir une vision comme ça synthétique
très rapidement et du coup de prendre
les meilleures décisions plus rapidement
avec
si c'est le cas de crise il ya des
personnes en danger être capable de
laisser courir le plus rapidement
possible par les deux situations de
crise par exemple pour les forces de
l'ordre quel type de délinquance
nécessite une innovation permanente sur
les moyens technologiques c'est par
exemple on s'aperçoit que les risques
actuels a un peu changé il ya de plus en
plus de cambriolages par exemple il faut
que le département sont pas bons
d'ailleurs et qui augmentent il faut
trouver des nouveaux moyens de contrer
ces problèmes-là donc notamment le fait
d'avoir sur une table une cartographie
qui met des statistiques de des endroits
où on lieu les cambriolages les plus
fréquemment permet d'adapter les rondes
les surveillances sur ces zones là qui
sont des zones ayant plus de risques à
ce moment là puisque ça bouge énormément
d'un quartier à l'autre notamment dans
les périodes effectivement de vacances
où là il ya beaucoup moins de personnes
donc ce type d'outils permet d'anticiper
et de mieux préparer une intervention
est de focaliser les moyens là où ils
sont nécessaires et comment naissent ces
innovations ce sont justement les
utilisateurs potentiels qui vous font
des retours et qui vous dit si on avait
tel outil éventuellement ce serait plus
simple pour appréhender par exemple pour
les cambriolages ou alors ce sont plutôt
du côté des des scientifiques des
chercheurs qui imaginent de technologie
qui pourrait servir et de sang et or les
deux exactement et c'est ça la richesse
du pps m c'est dire qu'on met ces deux
communautés qui se parlent peu on les
met ensemble les opérationnels
réagissent sur une démonstration sur une
technologie qu'il voire 10 ans mais je
pourrais utiliser de cette façon là et
les chercheurs aussi comprennent qu'ils
pourraient proposer autre chose quelque
chose de plus simple en général c'est
tout la tendance à faire des choses très
compliquées en réalité alors que ce qui
est important c'est souvent l'ergonomie
la facilité d'utilisation des choses sur
lesquelles on regarde pas assez tout le
dispositif est né du précédent
gouvernement la précédente majorité de
nicolas sarkozy c'était une volonté du
ministère de l'intérieur et puis ensuite
à du du président vous avez eu un moment
une crainte de voir ce dispositif
disparaître avec un politique non n'a
pas et en santé on a ressenti parce que
de toute façon nous on est sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
on travaille avec les acteurs locaux et
de toute façon entre la communauté
d'agglomération saint quentin en
yvelines est lente et ma gauche et la
ville et l'emporter sa droite j'avais en
tête voilà on a déjà on a déjà trouvé
des besoins communs qui était d'admirer
la sécurité ils fonctionnement des
services de secours donc là-dessus il
n'y a aucun conflit sur les mêmes
intérêts sont servis non seulement les
politiques qui s'intéressent un toujours
au travail que vous menez puisque
récemment le maire de la ville
d'elancourt a convié en c'était en début
de semaine le président du conseil
général des yvelines et une visite pour
découvrir les travaux que vous veniez on
revient sur cette visite avec valérie
auribeau
police nationale municipale pompiers et
le pôle pilote de sécurité locale
d'elancourt ses services bientôt
travailleront de concert pour intervenir
au plus vite sur le terrain le but
gagner du temps pour sauver encore plus
de vie le pps elle est un centre pour
tester les nouvelles technologies dans
le domaine de la sécurité pour les
forces de secours des forces de police
qui ont besoin d'intervenir très
rapidement d'échanger de l'information
et de comprendre ce qui se passe sur
deux situations en offrent les
technologies qui permettent d'y répondre
analyse de cartographie étude des zones
à risque utilisation des réseaux sociaux
en cas de crise grâce à ces nouvelles
technologies la qualité la rapidité et
la précision de l'information s'accroît
pour un meilleur rendu sur le terrain et
entre les services c'est pas un hasard
si le pp est celle entre guillemets est
à quelques mètres du commissariat c'est
bien sûr pour qu'ils synergie d
expérimentation et bien sûr et des
nounous
nous nos équipes de police à avoir le
meilleur matériel le plus performant une
performance qui passe par le partenariat
avec plus de 50 grandes et petites
entreprises qui offrent leur technologie
et leur savoir au service de la sécurité
et des forces de secours
voilà pour cette visite ce tour du côté
du pp est celle du côté d'el en cours
dans le reportage il a été mentionné 50
entreprises partenaires ça fluctue sa
varier de plus en plus d'entreprises
souhaitent justement intégrer ce cercle
tout à fait parce qu'on commence à être
connu non seulement au niveau français
au niveau européen donc on est sollicité
par des sociétés même
étrangère pour monter des projets de
recherche européens on en a notamment un
sur les réseaux sociaux cds citée dans
le reportage qui vient juste de démarrer
donc le principe de ce projet c'est
utiliser les réseaux sociaux en cas de
crise pour retrouver de l'information
par exemple si une personne qui disparut
que c'était passé réellement donc avoir
de l'information partir des réseaux et
aussi dans l'autre sens il ya besoin
d'informer la population sur là où il
faut se regrouper là où sont les
hôpitaux qui ont plus de disponibilité
pouvoir transmettre l'information la au
travers des réseaux sociaux donc ça
c'est un projet qu'on nous on nous a
sollicités pour participer à ce projet
là et on était sollicité par des
entreprises européennes qui intéresse
donc bientôt le monde entier un ce ppsl
quel avenir justement pour le psn alors
on vous voyait par la suite parce qu'il
va falloir des applications oui mise en
application cette facile et voilà des
réalisations concrètes sur le terrain
alors on a commencé j'ai parlé j'ai
commencé enfin vous l'avez vu en
démonstration d'un terminal mobile qui
peut équiper les forces de police pour
avoir les pompiers les services
techniques des villes pour avoir leurs
informations avec eux capables de
prendre des notes de façon très rapide
et échanger de l'information entre eux
ou avec des niveaux de commandement ce
type d'application j'espère qu'on l'aura
déployer très rapidement
c'est effectivement ce type de résultat
qui peut aussi montrer que on apporte
des solutions concrètes c'est pas
simplement de la théorie de la recherche
n'est pas le juste une vitrine voilà
c'est pas juste une vitrine on se fait
des choses pour l'utilisation de tous
les jours merci jacqueline argent est
revenue sur plateau pour ces précisions
autour du pôle pilote de sécurité locale
qui est implantée à elancourt avec la
participation des différentes
entreprises de la communauté
d'agglomération volonté politique est
également des entreprises partenariat
public privé depuis trois ans maintenant
merci à vous la suite du 7 8 7 avec de
l'économie mais déjà du sport hier soir
la ville de plaisir recevez un des
quarts de finale de la coupe de la ligue
de handball féminin à la fédération qui
dans les yvelines voulait profiter de
l'occasion pour valoriser cette
discipline c'est plutôt réussi une salle
comble pour un très beau spectacle les
images dont anthony rech
mios-biganos bassin d'arcachon face au
havre en bleu un quart de finale de
coupe de la ligue féminine de handball
explosif à plaisir au palais des sports
pierre de coubertin le suspense aura
duré jusqu'à la dernière seconde et
c'est pourtant l'équipe du havre de la
gardienne linda pradel natif de trappes
qui prend le meilleur départ quelques
buts signés 1a de souza donne le ton
presque à domicile
celle qui évolue également en équipe de
france doit faire face au relâchement de
ses coéquipières après la pause à
égalité après sept minutes les deux
équipes jouent au chat et à la souris
c'est l'international serbe jovana
stojkovic qui arrache l'avantagent pour
le havre 26 25 et c'est le havre qui va
s'imposer grâce à sa gardienne justement
elle linda pradel elle signe son sixième
et ultime arrêt de la rencontre sur ce
coup de sifflet final de l arbitre
j'étais super bien accueilli c'est vrai
que ben voilà avec le sport on n'a pas
trop l'occasion
de revenir un petit peu voir la famille
et tout donc là ça m'a fait plaisir en
question par tout le monde et d'être là
et même l'organisation
les présidents de clubs de la fin
c'était super comme à la maison
linda pradel et le havre sur le terrain
d'ici paris pour la demi-finale
rencontre programmée jeudi soir et une
volonté de l'emporter pour les normandes
d'autant plus forte qu'en février elle
était éliminé de la coupe d'europe pour
les instances locales l'opération
séduction est en tout cas un succès la
rencontre a permis d'accueillir quelques
1200 personnes reste à voir les
incidences sur les inscriptions dans les
clubs dans les prochains mois
actuellement elles sont 2000 à jouer au
hand dans les yvelines